this is a chance for you to say
something without any repercussions
Stanley Oscar come on
I will go first
when I discovered YouTube I didn't work
for five days I did nothing I viewed
Cookie Monster sings Chocolate Rain
about a thousand times what was the
Dilemma
to tell you or not
and I'm glad I did I feel very very good
so how do you search by keyword phrase
try profits no try Michael Scott
Michael boss and funny
wow email from Stanley Stanley terribly
nice guy sorry I didn't write back
sooner I can't go to the game tonight
because my boss Michael is an ass and
making me stay late well Stanley said
yes it is true I Michael Scott am
signing up with an online dating service
thousands of people have done it and I
am going to do it I need a username
and I have a great one
little kid lover that way people will
know exactly where my priorities are at
work
this is parkour internet sensation of
2004 and it was in one of the Bond films
it's pretty impressive the goal is to
get from point A to point B as
creatively as possible so technically
they are doing parkour as long as point
a is delusion and point B is the
hospital
okay
[Applause]
come on jump over the camera jump over
the camera
okay we all go together or we go one at
a time here it is here it is uh truck
two refrigerators two dumpster 360 spin
onto the palace backflip Gainer into the
trash
Hardcore Parkour
parkour
everybody we are at Defcon 5. I am
officially the second most watched clip
of the day on the wbre news site what's
number one oh that teacher who is
wrongfully accused of being a pedophile
now we cannot let the pedophile win
again I would like you all to go to the
website and watch my clip 11 times so
instead of working yes okay yes
you see this report that the zoo got a
baby otter it's on the same site oh it's
kissing it's Mommy please all you have
to see this is like the cutest thing
ever
really a baby otter okay
um Count Me In as who cares it's not
even that interesting a baby otter it
can't even stand up
trying to stand up
there he goes
[Applause]
why don't you just buy the whole song
I don't have to buy it
I just want to taste it
I just want a little taste of it
hey dude just got back from Jamaica
[Music]
yeah that sounds amazing but you know
what the lady Jan Levinson want to go to
Montego Bay you
know I don't
well I'm looking at a photo right now
and I'm telling you it could be a maxim
they wouldn't give you a subscription to
maximum oh no
okay well
check this out
I'm sending you some email
you got it
no I
check it again hit refresh
okay wait a second I sent it to you
at Packer Dunder mifflin.com
wait
I just got it from somebody else
wow
this is hot damn
how do I get you out of this picture
Daryl
hey
where's Daryl today in the office okay
hi hey
man how's it going all right what's up
Mike that's great okay
um so did you get an email from me yeah
okay
well that was supposed to go to Packer
not packaging did you already
um forward it to a whole bunch of people
uh-huh okay okay
um
well did you get the second email that I
sent
explaining that the first email was a
mistake and that you should delete it
yep and you sent that ass to everyone
Mike I'm very busy down here
I can already feel people stress
starting to melt
I think they're very excited about
paying their respects this way
I've got to make sure that YouTube comes
down to tape this
foreign
ask me for a raise because I need to try
out some of these negotiation tactics on
you where'd you get that Wikipedia
Wikipedia
is the best thing ever
anyone in the world can write anything
they want about any subject so you know
you are getting the best possible
information
proceed straight
well we're out for six
Last Chance is the Elmhurst Country Club
other side of the lake on the Southeast
side I'll get it you really don't get it
I thought this would work
through everything I had at that guy
nothing that's how it goes sometimes you
know
you lose everything and everything falls
apart and eventually you die and no one
remembers you that is a very good point
make a right turn
wait wait wait wait wait no no no it
means Bear right
not there it said right it said take a
right no no no no no look it means go up
to the right Bear right over the bridge
and hook up with 307. make a right maybe
it's a shortcut Dwight it said go to the
right it can't mean that there's a
lightning it knows where it is going the
machine
remain calm I have trained for this okay
exit the window here we go make a U-turn
if possible
[Music]
are you okay swim for it
I got you I got it
back up
come on
come on
come on come on
thanks for meeting me are you kidding
I'd come anywhere to see a turtle yeah
where'd you find him
there's no Turtle Michael I just wanted
to get you here oh
you know me very well Dwight that's
because I'm your right hand man Michael
but I can't do it I can't do it again I
can't be a right-hand man to a whole new
guy now I'm gonna have to go online and
look at turtles or else I'm gonna be off
the whole time